you believe in ghosts no no not only do
I not believe in it but I get annoyed
when people do how so well I mean come
on It's too convenient the same friend
also told me one about where he stayed
at this place in Birmingham in the UK
and all manner of it ended up happening
to him while he was in this room and
they didn't want to let him stay you're
not supposed to stay there anyway the
doors start smashing open and closed and
the windows do and then within the next
week the whole life just comes crashing
down around him wow and then he's
walking through Hollywood when he gets
back and this Gypsy lady comes up to him
and says sorry I don't mean to disturb
you you know you've got a dark shadow
that's following you and she takes him
in and does the thing and I was like you
know and this guy is like super super
rational again for me I'm very much like
if I can't see it I won't believe it but
it really freaks me out to hear stuff
like that I believe in energies and
Vibes and all that stuff you know
there's all kinds of things going on
around we're all connected we live on
Earth for so long coincidences are gonna
happen